hey guys it's Jonah here I'm sure we all
have our own beliefs and truths when it
comes to getting fit if you're new to
fitness you might unknowingly be
influenced by some of the inaccurate
advice given by those around you we all
want quick results and we want to do the
right things to achieve that so let's
talk about the top 10 fitness myths you
need to stop believing the first myth is
I must work out in the morning there is
no evidence saying that if you work out
in the morning you will be burning more
calories throughout the day yes I do
agree that if you work out in the
morning chances of you giving yourself
excuses not to work out later on in the
day will be less it can also boost your
energy and mood throughout the day but
if you can't find time to work out in
the morning working out in the evening
will be equally just as beneficial the
key here is to work out when it is most
convenient for you because that way you
are more likely to stick to your workout
routine next I mother eat late at night
or I'll be fat do you know of some
people who would restrict themselves
from eating after a certain hour because
they truly believe that if they eat late
at night they will be fat that is an
absolute myth ok eating late at night
will not make you fat as long as you
stay within your daily calorie needs it
is not about the timing of when you
consume your food but rather the total
amount of food you eat in a day if you
consume more calories than what your
body needs then yes you would gain
weight the reason why this myth exists
is because when it's lit at night we
tend to eat mindlessly out of boredom
tightness or habit we're also more
likely to make poor food choices such as
munching on chips or ice cream while
watching TV and as a result you tend to
eat more than what your body needs and
you gain weight but remember it has
nothing to do with the time of the thing
eating too many calories regardless of
the time of the day can lead to weight
gain everybody must have heard this next
statement before oh I'm trying to lose
weight I'm staying away from cars first
of all let's understand what our carbs
either list here whole-grain rice pasta
bread green leafy vegetables fruits
legumes cakes muffins and fries all
these are cups it is not about cutting
cups but rather choosing the right cups
to help you with a witness process the
good carbs such as vegetables whole
fruit legumes beans potatoes and whole
grain will provide your body with
sustained energy curve hunger and keep
your waistline happy on the other hand
the bed refined cup such as cakes
pastries processed foods sugar sweetened
beverages can cause your blood sugar
level to spike which leads to hunger and
craving for more bad fruits they are
empty calories with almost no nutrients
and will cut you to gain weight
especially fat around the belly so
remember cups will not lead to weight
gain
it is about choosing the right cups and
getting rid of the bad comes next all
calories are the same what you eat
determines 80% of your success where you
get your calories from plays a huge role
and not all calories are the same
different foods process differently in
your body a diet rich with whole cups
healthy fat clean protein and vegetables
will provide you with sustained energy
curve hunger with your work a
performance energy level and you'll have
healthier hair and skin in contrast if
your diet consists of processed food or
junk with very low nutrients trust me
you will constantly feel tired low in
energy
you will feel hungry you will crave for
more bad sugary and salty food and as a
result you will be eating more calories
than what your body needs to pick the
right food for your body and you
wouldn't need to restrict yourself or go
crazy about counting calories myth
number 5 it's all about the numbers on
the skill the skill is in fact the most
inaccurate way to measure your witness
progress what we should be looking at is
our body composition the muscle to fat
ratio muscle is about 18% more dense
compared
is that the one pound of muscle takes up
less space compared to one pound of fat
so if you have been training and you
have been losing inches and your clothes
fit better but the skill hasn't budged
well don't worry
that's because you are losing body fat
and gaining lean muscles at the same
time and you are heading towards to the
right direction 6 if I lift weights
I'll be big and bulky look I've been
saying this too many times we women do
not have enough muscle building hormones
to pack on the muscle masks easily as
men view those women body builders that
we see in the magazines do not just lift
weights and eat clean to achieve that
figure in fact they have a very strict
specific diet and even take specific
supplements to achieve their figure so
know ladies you will not bulk up just by
lifting weights in fact weight lifting
will gives you beautiful curves and you
will achieve a taller and stronger look
next I want to lose belly fat I need to
do more crunches I hope you're not one
of those people who do 100 crunches
every single day and hope that the belly
fat would melt away I have a bad news
for you
you cannot spot reduce that doing lots
of crunches or other ab exercises can
help you to strengthen your core muscles
but it will not get rid of that belly
fat you have to combine total body
strength training and cardio exercises
to burn the belly fat layer off do check
out my workout videos to help you get
started myth number AIDS to lose weight
fast I need to do more cardio yes
traditional cardio will help to create a
day-to-day calorie deficit and it will
help with weight loss but it is only
short-term for a long lasting permanent
change you have to integrate strength
training into your routine strength
training builds lean muscle mass which
will increase your metabolic rate and
turn your body into a fat-burning
machine even when you're not exercising
for best results combine both cardio and
strength training next the longer of the
more I work out the quicker I'll achieve
results it is not about the length of
your workout but rather the intensity of
your workout so shorter intense workouts
will
to be more effective in burning fat and
you will achieve your weight loss goal
quicker so a solid 30 minute shot an
intense workout session with very little
rest in between it's actually more
effective in comparison to a long one
our low intensity workout session
however that doesn't mean you should be
performing high intensity workouts every
single day and not give time for your
body to rest and recover when your body
is resting you're allowing your muscle
fibers to reduce and become stronger yes
we want to train hard but not over train
overtraining can cause prolonged muscle
soreness lethargic trouble sleeping you
might be missing your period and you
might even hit a plateau so I like to
bring my workouts into two days of
high-intensity training two days of
strength training and two days of just
easy training such as gentle yoga or
brisk walking so the good news is you
don't have to train hard seven days a
week to achieve the results you want and
the final myth is I'm not sweating
enough therefore I'm not getting a good
workout the amount you sweat does not
determine how many calories you've
burned or if you had a solid workout
when you exercise your body heats up
sweating is a natural response to help
your body to cool down how much you
sweat is determined by different factors
the temperature you workout in humidity
and how fit you are you're not going to
sweat as much in coded climates and the
fitter you are the faster you will sweat
because your body's air conditioning
system would turn on quicker but that's
not always the case as we are all
different so instead of focusing on how
much you sweat focus on how hard you
push yourself at every workout and
remember to always give your best so
these are some of the common questions I
get asked every so often I hope this
video has helped debunk some of the
Finnick myths you might have heard what
other myths have you come across let me
know in the comments below so if you
find this video to be helpful to give
this video a thumb up share it and
subscribe to my youtube channel for new
videos every Monday Wednesday and Friday
do also turn on your notification button
so that
we'll get notified every time I upload a
new video all the best